Andie's highly-anticipated nabi series
is going to be hitting the GPU market
very soon so how is it going to affected
and should you wait for it welcome to
Haris hobbies so first of all I would
like to discuss the performance of the
new navi series this is the performance
isn't good but nothing else really
matters
currently Polaris is on the 40 nanometer
process and Nabi is going to push it on
to seven in a meter process the 11 or
series is expected to be on the tall
nanometer process so Navi will be on the
most advanced process on the GPU market
Global Foundries suggests that since the
7 an Emir process delivers twice the
logic density as the 40 nanometer
process we should be seeing a huge
performance upgrade as up to 40% AMT
themselves have confirmed that the Navi
series will be coming with GT dr6 memory
or HBO to memory which are both
significant upgrades or rigidity of 5x
and ddr4 memory plan on previous
generations of AMD graphics cards and
Nvidia graphics cards ami is also trying
to implement a new multi-gpu type of
module into Navi series similar to their
Rison series using infinity fabric this
would make a huge difference in terms of
performance because performance will be
much more scalable with Infinity fabric
however aim D is having some issues with
implementing this technology into the
Navi series so we may not see it just
yet despite that the Navi series will
most likely be a solid generational
increment and that's not a bad thing
because the 11 her series from Nvidia
seems to be the same way at least on the
mid-level GPUs which probably won't have
temperature cores or rate racing
technology and in the end these GPUs
will most likely end up being great
counterparts for the mid-range level of
GPUs for NVIDIA NVIDIA GPUs will do
better on some games and AMD GPUs will
do better on other games but in the end
is pretty much the same performance well
what about pricing for the Navi series
right now pricing for the 500 series is
absolutely atrocious well here's the
good news
aim DS pricing is usually better than in
videos so unless something big happens
like another cryptocurrency mining room
we should be good for example
the GTX 1066 Cabaye card an RX 580 a Qi
card are identical
however the 1060 card comes in at $300
while the RS 580 comes at $230 as for
MSRP so it's quite a significant
difference and AMD is able to offer
identical performance for a much cheaper
price
and since aimed is the underdog in this
market we will most likely see this
trend continuing forward in an effort to
persuade people to buy their GPUs over
invidious and build trust
so overall unless there are some huge
outside influences Ami's counterparts
NVIDIA GPUs will be cheaper but what
exactly is this GPU coming out again
well according to aim DS official
roadmap na VI is said to come out
sometime in 2019
and many rumors are suggesting that it
will actually come out before the end of
the first quarter however it may take up
until the second quarter or third
quarter port to actually come out so it
is quite a while away still and so if
you need a GPU then this is not the time
to wait for this so how does not me
stack up against the 11 or series and
should you consider getting this over
the 11 curve series well unfortunately
aim D is not known for their high level
GPU performance and usually when you
match the performance between an AMD and
NVIDIA card the AMD counterpart is
usually less power efficient but
hopefully the new process helps a lot
with that we are not really sure how it
will perform a Guinness and because
higher level cards and we really just
have to wait and see but as of now there
is really no reason to wait all the way
to AMD Navi when the ulema is yours is
coming out much sooner
so in essence aim DS Dobby series seems
to be a great alternative to the 11 her
Suri's for a possibly cheaper price but
it's nothing major though but that's
just what I think what do you guys think
do you guys think that AMD Navi is going
to be a complete game changer or do you
think they'll just be a nice upgrade
over the last series make sure to
comment down below what you guys think
because I do all my comments on the
curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like this video then make sure
drop a like and consider subscribing if
you'd like to see more videos just like
this one
but until then
all right I'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]